[Music]  take a bottle of sprite put a cork in it  boom champagne  [Music]  here's here's bill with another tip bill  [Music]  take an old restraining order  draw a heart on it  boom valentine  [Applause]  [Music]  here's bill with another one  [Music]  take a thong put a stake in it  boom edible underwear  [Music]  [Applause]  here's another one  [Music]  don't pay your electricity bill for six  months boom mood lighting  [Music]  here's bill with another one  take a ball write sex on it  boom sex toy  there's another one  take six roses cross your eyes boom a  dozen roses  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  that's  so criminally stupid  there's another one  take a picture of me show it to your  wife  boom aphrodisiac  it  [Applause]  works it works  great show